bonjour et merci de prendre le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
on évoque le chiffre de 20 millions
d'emplois qui pourraient disparaître aux
etats-unis en avril est ce que c'est un
chiffre qui vous semblent plausibles
absolument s'il comptait les chômeurs
comme ceux qui sont disponibles dès
travailler et qu'ils ont essayé de
travailler dans les derniers à quatre
semaines pendant le lock 1 c'est juste
l'arithmétique donc presque 16% de la
force de travail c'est à dire 16
millions de personnes proxi tube man qui
cherche maintenant un petit soldes pour
10000 bout de moi c'est ils sont dans
les désespérés à sion est la réserve
fédérale américaine a annoncé 2300
milliards de dollars de nouveaux prêts
pour relancer l économie le congrès de
son côté avaliser un plan de mesures
notamment pour aider les chauffeurs est
ce que on peut parler d'un changement de
cap dans la politique économique de
donald trump
comment est ce que vous voyez les choses
ah oui il était esseulé promesse de
réduire les dépenses sociales il était
républicain dans toutes ses sols de
socialisme et contraire la soul ans
tente mais c'est vrai on aurait crise
tout le monde vienne 15 yens ils
dépensent des grosses sommes d'argent
le problème maintenant c'est les
distributions donc en grèce a placé en
loire que 2 millions des millions de
dollars d'autres fouilles en dollars
soit dépensé mais comment libre et cet
argent aux gens la grèce notre service
fiscal doivent faire les rennais sur les
comptes bancaires comme ce nombre
d'individus mais pour l'instant que cela
résout l'argent' sauf bien sûr intégral
société qu'un récit qui a reçu 500
milliards de dollars
je suis est ce que cela pourrait peser
sur la campagne présidentielle
novembre et sur celle de donald trump
s'il ne parvient pas à faire baisser le
chômage comment est-ce que réagi
l'opinion commune aux états unis.le
l'opinion soutiennent le présidente a
spécifiquement 30
mais il ya un soutien pour la présidente
pendant les 32 crise mais la marjorie de
crise et seulement c'est un des treize
clé dans le président siki été j ai une
crise or avoir un scandale
donc maintenant la question c'est est-ce
que ils ne réussirent de faire remonter
le taux de travail ce qui va retourner
les gens dans le force de l'économie os
que le long terme continue ou si ça
continue ça serait catastrophique pour
son président si possible élection on a
entendu un donald trump tout à l'heure
qui se veut rassurant au plan sanitaire
notamment comment est-ce que vous
analysez sa gestion de la crise le mode
gestion n'arrive pas dans ma tête il
était vraiment encore potence était en
stand de télévision ghilas est une
qualité mais les gérances d'un crises
pandémiques n'est pas une il utilisait
un deux heures par jour pour faire une
sorte de campagne aux élections mais où
ils critiquent ses opposantes
il traque les journalistes mais autour
de l'oubli un an ce nombre des gens
qu'ils ont réussi à convaincre les états
unis comme d'autres comme d'autres
faut-il par exemple
et il semble prendre pour l'instant il
va se fait sur l'opinion publique
populaire du président mais un hôtel au
début il a nié qu'il y ait eu des milk
doute c enregistrés après il a viré
tellement des gens compétents qu'ils
étaient entrés par les ja semaine c'est
à dire les gens qui n'osent pas le
contredire et même pendant ces deux
heures de discours chaque soir ils
contredisent son propre experton nord
c'est un mal gérance merci beaucoup pour
votre regard de glace y est professeur
de droit et spécialiste de sciences
politiques à mende